irma continues to move toward florida
where it's expected to turn north by
sunday where it turns will make a huge
difference especially in areas like the
florida keys they are under a mandatory
evacuation order traffic has been heavy
on u.s route one that is the only
highway out as many as 25 thousand
people have already left elaine cajano
is in key largo that's on the eastern
edge of the keys elaine good morning
good morning to you norah well it is a
picturesque scene right now here at the
pilot house marina in key largo in fact
we've actually found a few folks who say
they plan on riding out the storm right
here but officials are telling us if you
do decide to stay you're on your
own how are you three days before
hurricane irma is forecasted to hit
florida nobody will be left here at the
house that we have to worry about
monroe county sheriff sergeant scott
ward is making sure people in the keys
are getting out do you have any idea how
many people are left you have no way of
knowing right
no ma'am
a mandatory evacuation order is in
effect for visitors and the roughly 80
thousand people who live here preparing
our house isn't the bad part it's
getting on the road not knowing what
we're going to run into
a caravan of cars and trucks lying the
only highway out of town on wednesday
gas stations along a 120-mile stretch of
route 1 quickly ran out of gas i guess
i'll be
stranded
something taking an uber a long
expensive ride on uber
on the water crews are hauling boats
into storage
but not thomas wilson he's ridden out
four hurricanes on his boat irma will be
his fifth if he decides to stay
how worried are you about this storm
i'm worried about it too this one could
be a killer
wilson says he plans to decide whether
to stay on saturday all three hospitals
in the keys are evacuating and will be
closed by friday morning key west
international airport will shut down
later today gail people are being warned
thank you very much elaine